[Music]
elizabeth warren lyowatha
pocahontas
herself
senator high cheekbones
is introducing legislation
to
not to help women
not to give women a choice
not to support all that choice and
women's lib that she always prattles on
about she's introducing legislation
to shut down
crisis pregnancy centers
in massachusetts right now
those
crisis pregnancy centers
that are there
to fool people who are looking for
pregnancy termination help
outnumber
true abortion clinics by three to one we
need to shut them down here in
massachusetts and we need to shut them
down all around the country
you should not be able
to torture a pregnant person like that
you're torturing a pregnant person she
says formerly known as a woman you're a
mother you're torturing a mother she
says if you offer her free or extremely
low cost resources to take care of her
child
crisis pregnancy centers are wonderful
they are actual pregnancy centers to
help actual pregnant women
without killing their children the one
thing you can't get at a crisis
pregnancy center is
uh
killing your children just like how at
planned parenthood planned parenthood
pretends to be a big pregnancy center
that serves all women and all sorts of
women's health care but you can't get
all sorts of women's health care at
planned parenthood their chief product
is abortion so if you want to kill your
kid you go to planned parenthood if you
want help with your pregnancy if you're
if you're a struggling mother and you
you want help
during the pregnancy itself or with
birth or just afterward for young
mothers you go to a crisis pregnancy
center
i have had the privilege of speaking
with all sorts of crisis pregnancy
centers they do
truly they do god's work on earth liz
warren wants to shut them down why
because she doesn't want a choice at the
very least we've got to get rid of this
pro-choice moniker
they do not want a choice they want you
to kill your kid
they do not want you to just make an
informed decision they don't want you to
make an informed decision they want to
shut down
the centers that will take care of you
if you want to keep your child and they
want to federally fund the centers that
will help you kill your child
that's it it reminds me of this
conversation
between betty friedam the american
feminist and simone de bevoir who was
the strumpet of jean-paul sartre and she
was a french feminist and they had a
debate over whether or not uh women
should have the choice to stay at home
and betty friedan said yeah if a woman
wants to go work she can if she wants to
stay at home she can and that's great
she can have the choice and simone de
beauvoir said no she can't have the
choice to stay home
if women have the choice to stay home
they'll take that choice nine times out
of ten and that's not conducive to
liberation we have to force them to go
to the workplace liz warren is saying we
have to force them to kill their kids
basically if a woman is poor if she's in
trouble if she's worried if she's
anxious it's an unexpected pregnancy we
need to force her to kill the baby
we can't give her the choice because
it's all about power
and more broadly it's about serving a
broader system it's not about
a woman's individual choice right now go
to all form dot com slash knowles i have
invited you into my bedroom you know
that i've told you all about my
beautiful helix mattress well
now helix has left the bedroom they've
started making sofas they just launched
a new company called all form they are
already making the best sofas we have
ever seen on this show it is a fabulous
sofa for a lot of reasons one you get to
customize a sofa using premium materials
you do it at a fraction of the cost of
traditional stores you pick the fabric
the color the color of the legs the size
this shape to make sure it's a perfect
fit for your home they've got arm chairs
and love seats all the way up to an
eight seat sectional and what i really
love let's say you're in a studio
apartment right now someday you're gonna
live in a mansion you can add more seats
as your home grows really really high
quality stuff they have a forever
warranty that is literally forever to
find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com
knowles that's all form dot com slash
knowles they're offering 20 off all
orders for our listeners allform.com
knowles we need to reintroduce
logic and reason to the discussion
the left broadly
has been trying to take logic and reason
out of our politics that's why they're
taking away the meaning of all the words
if words don't have meaning anymore or
if the meanings of words change every
single day then we can't communicate we
can't have a civil dialogue we can't
have reason debate politics ceases to be
this reasoned
process of figuring out how best we can
live the good life and how we can have a
flourishing country and it becomes a
bare-knuckle brawl for raw interest and
will
i want it and i want it now and that's
why i'm going to get it that's that's
not a good way to do politics we need to
reintroduce logic especially to this
discussion around abortion
do you know where we're hearing this
from not just from the conservatives in
america not just from the right wingers
we're even hearing this from
the holy father from the pope who is not
the most conservative guy in the world
some people think he's very very far to
the left and he has
said and done things that would justify
that belief even the pope was just asked
about joe biden's stance on abortion
how joe biden supports abortion
and here is what
pope francis said about this he said
let biden talk to his pastor about that
incoherence
he called
i frankly i sort of wish that pope
francis were even
tougher here and were even more clear
but this phrase is pretty clear he's
saying that joe biden's defense of
abortion is incoherence and it is
incoherence
to defend abortion is incoherent to for
someone who enjoys the right to life
to advocate
denying the right to life is
intrinsically incoherent
you might say it's satanic there's a
video going around i have to get to this
video i meant to get to it yesterday
of of a young woman
giggling over abortion this woman she's
got all sorts of face tattoos she's got
us a satanic symbol on her chest
and she's watching a video of a kind of
satanic demonic looking figure killing
and torturing a baby and she's laughing
and she's giggling and she's getting a
really big kick out of it she says it's
my favorite tik tok i've seen this week
hahaha
there are all sorts of
secular explanations for this the libs
and
some of the conservatives even will say
oh this is really this is about
leftism this is about progressivism this
is about marxism this is about
this is a metaphor they're trying to
metaphorize everything you know satan's
really just a metaphor for a man's
natural capacity for evil
sometimes guys
it's just the devil
and actual it's kind of like that iq
bell curve mean at the bottom end of the
iq curve they say
everything is about
the goodness of god
and there's the evil of the devil and we
gotta we gotta pursue god
right and then the people in the middle
the midwits they say well actually you
know it's a metaphor and it's a metaphor
for this aspect of the internal turmoil
and chaos of man's soul and then you get
up to the really smart guys at the top
and they say no it's really it's just
about good versus evil it's just about
god
and the temptations of the devil and
you've got to pursue god and that's what
this is about
people have been worshipping the devil
for a lot longer than there has been
leftism or marxism
they all kind of play into the same
thing but every culture everywhere
around the world has had some conception
of god and some conception of the devil
reminds me of that line from antonin
scalia where he was being mocked by a
new york magazine reporter
and the reporter said wait you believe
in heaven and hell he goes uh-huh i do
he says you know i even believe in the
devil
and she he said you're looking at me
like i'm weird do you realize that most
people throughout history have believed
in in the devil that the devil exists
do you
do you realize that many more
intelligent people than you and me have
believed that the devil exists it's a
very important line it's a very
important thing to remember when we're
when we're trying to make sense of these
political problems
sometimes listen to the the dumb guy at
the end of the iq bell curve meme
sometimes
all the time actually it really does
come down to good versus evil those
things that we try to write away as
abstractions and metaphors and just mere
images those have reality and we need to
deal with that because we are imperiling
our country and ourselves if we ignore
it i'm so glad you liked that clip now
here's what i need from you i need if
you haven't done it already i need you
to ring that bell i need you to ring
that bell because we are very very close
to 1 million subscribers and i really
want that gold play button that they're
going to send me they're going to send
me the gold play button and then they're
going to nuke my channel right that's
inevitable but i want the play button
first so make sure you get those
notifications ring that bell ding dong
whatever you got to do we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you